END.
>> Mike: AND SCHRODER WITH SOME
BIG BUCKETS SECOND HALF.
>> Mark: HOW ABOUT THE FEED
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ] FORCING
TO MISS AND ALLOWING THE HEAT
TO GET THE  JUST ACHIUWA.
D ASSIST!
THE SPIN MOV
EXPLODE OFF THE RIGHT SIDE.CED
BY MINNESOTA COMING OUTMUCH HEL
THE PAINT, ANDRUBIO'S STYLE OF .
GOT IT!
FOR THE KID FROM RECOGNIZES
DA CLUTCH FREE THROWS THERE
FROM RANDLE.
OF DOUBLE-TEAMING AND DOING TOO
MUCH,, GO.
HO BY JORDAN.
AHEADS ALL ABOUT
TRANSITION.
SKYSCR
LOOK AT THIS, IT'S AMAZING.  CO!
ON THE AND HE'S AWARE
WHNMU HAS TO BLOCK
JOSEPH. ROTATION, AND A
GREAT BLOCK.
THIS IS WHERE GIANNIS IS AT HIS.
OH!
TH RUNWAY.
OH, BABY!
BEHIND HIM, THROWS IT DOWN.BASK.
>> Austin: AND IT'S QUICK